ذكرت صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت كان وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيليه مارلين قرر رفع مستوى
التاهب في السجون واغلاق الزنازين امام
حركه الاسرى واضافت الصحيفه ان بنجافيه
وجهها بابلاغ الاسرى في السجون بانه هم
اذا بداوا اضرابا عن الطعام او اعمال شغب
فسيتم التضييق عليهم
انا من امام سجن عوفر العسكريه الاسرائيلي
شمال القدس مراسلتنا نجوان سمرينا
داخل السجون سجن عوفر على وجه التحديد مع
سريان هذه الاجراءات التي امر بها بنجافير
نعم مريم هناك حاله استنفار في كافه
السجون التي يقبع بها الاسرى الفلسطينيون
هنا في سجن عوفر صباح هذا اليوم وبحسب عده
مؤسسات فلسطينيه تعنى بشؤون الاسرى قالت
بانه وقعت مواجهه صباح هذا اليوم مع وصول
نبا استشهاد الشيخ خضر عدنان مواجهه بين
احد الاسرى واحد
السجانين فلاجات اداره هذا السجن العسكري
المقام شمال القدس المحتله الى استخدام
الغاز البسيل للدموع داخل
الزنازين
وكانت هناك محاولات لقمع ايضا اي احتجاجات
ضد او على استشهاد الشهيد مع
تحميل الاحتلال من قبل الاسره الفلسطينيين
كالمسؤوليه الكامله على
الاحتلال بانه تعمد
انتاج سياسه الاهمال الطبي بحقه ما ادى
الى استشهاد خضر عدنان صباح هذا اليوم
هناك حاله من الاستنفار في كافه السجون لا
سيما مع البيان الذي صدر عن مكتب وزير
الامن القومي المتطرف لتمار بني كبير الذي
اعلن هو الاخر بانه سيتم التعامل بحزم
بحسب ما قاله مع الاسرى في حال اقدم الى
اي
تصرفات وصفها بانها اعمال شغب وسيتم سحب
منهم ما وصفه ايضا بالامتيازات وهي الحقوق
التي نالها الاسرى الفلسطينيون بعد نضالات
عده وبالتالي رغم تحذيرات صدرت عن الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه وتوصيات ايضا
بالتعامل بحذر وبانضباط بحسب ما ذكرته
صحيفه هذا اليوم مع اي احتجاجات قد تحصل
داخل السجون
اسرائيلي بهذا الشان تم صباح هذا اليوم
ناقل الجثمان الى معهد الطب العدلي في
مدينه تل ابيب ولكن حتى الان ايضا غير من
غير الواضح فيما اذا كانت ستقدم وزاره
الصحه الاسرائيليه على تشريح الجثمان لانه
العائله بطبيعه الحال ترفض ذلك تماشيا مع
الوصيه التي تركها الشهيد خضر عدنان لكن
القانون الاسرائيلي من جهه لا يسمح بتشريح
الجثامين دون موافقه العائله ولكن من جهه
اخرى هناك حالات استثنائيه يسمح بها
للتوقف وللتحقق من سبب الوفاه حتى الان لم
يتم الاعلان عن ذلك وبحسب مصادر اسرائيليه
تم نقل الجثمان الى معهد الطب العدلي من
اجل وضع الجثمان في الثلاجات وعلي هذه
ايضا نقطه اخرى قال المحامون بشانها في
حال تم الاعلان عن نيه الاحتلال
بتشريح الجثمان سيتم تقديم التماس الى
المحكمه العليا لمنع ذلك وفقا لمطلب
العائله ووفقا لوصيه الاسير لكن بشكل عام
الاسئله الشهيد عفوا بشكل عام هناك حاله
من الاستنفار فقط قبل يومين يوم الاحد
الماضي كانت هنا في محكمه عوفر التابعه
لهذا السجن العسكري محكمه مثلا امامها
الشيخ الشهيد خضر عدنان عبر تقنيه الفيديو
كونفرنس وقالت زوجته بانه كان يحتضر في
هذه الجلسه شكرا لك نجوان سمري من امام
سجن عوفره العسكريه الاسرائيلي شمال القدس